the cowboys okay may not be fine yeah
but
the cowboys may not be fine moving
forward with andy dalton
they did win the game yesterday over the
new york giants but then again
new york giants one of two new york
teams are now a combined 0 and 10
if only they played each other this year
there's a chance they wouldn't both be 0
and 16.
andy dalton now the starter let's hear
what dalton had to say after yesterday's
win
for a lot of people you want to be in
those situations tie ball game get a
chance to
go down two minute drive to win the game
and so
you know you want to instill confidence
in everybody i've obviously been in
these situations uh
multiple times and so it's it's a lot of
fun to be in
in those situations and so um fun to see
how everybody responded everybody came
out
made big plays michael gallup with two
incredible plays to
to get us down there and get his field
goal range and so
um you know that's that's why you play
this game for for moments like that
you know it's funny out of sight out of
mind we had forgotten about andy dalton
for the most part
that's just what happens and now andy
dalton is going to be front and center
let me just say this is another aside
i'm not trying to make light of the
situation the guy's gonna be playing
quarterback in the nfl we haven't seen
him talk for a while we haven't
taken him in for a while he could play
the devil in a movie
couldn't he i mean really not that he's
an evil guy he just has that look there
was that movie years ago tom cruise was
in and tim curry played the devil
he just has that look well anyway i know
what you're doing andy dalton i got you
andy dalton is back and uh what do you
think happens now going forward well i
listen this is why you make an
investment in a backup quarterback i
mean you know like we talked a little
bit last night on the
the pre-game show i mean this is andy
dalton's not chopped liver
certainly you could see that enough just
yesterday that he can come in
run the offense make plays he did a lot
of good stuff in cincinnati now is he
dak prescott no i don't think he's dak
prescott certainly not
prescott is special in his ability to
hit balls down the field stand in the
pocket
run do all those things andy dalton can
do it all
just not to that high of a level but uh
i don't think it's going to change a
whole lot for their team overall
i don't and that's why you make this a
type of investment i give them a lot of
credit
for having a guy like andy dalton there
and ready to go their team should not
fall apart will they be as high fly and
throwing the ball all over the field
like they were with dak prescott
i doubt it but i don't think it's gonna
change a whole lot i still think it's
gonna be
majority pass and then run the ball i
still think they're gonna take that same
approach and we'll see what andy's got
with this football team
when you think about the best years of
andy dalton with the cincinnati bengals
he had
players around him on offense now there
are still questions with the defense in
dallas
but he's got ezekiel he's got cd lamp
he's got amari cooper he's got michael
gallup he's got cedric wilson
right he's got an uh and now now look
the offensive line
not what it was but he's got an offense
around him that is a lot closer in line
to the teams that he had in cincinnati
when they went to the playoffs five
straight years and let's remember his
career began
in cincinnati five for five with playoff
appearance
the guy can play and remember when they
made that move now we thought well okay
this is a hedge against something
happening with dak if he doesn't
report for camp if he uses all of the
options available to him under the
franchise tag
stays away maybe holds out into the
regular season they have someone who can
play
but now the dak won't be able to play
they have someone who can play
and they're in the nfc east for crying
out loud
right now if andy dalton's on the
bengals forget about it steelers 4-0
ravens 4-1 brown's 4-1 you're left in
the dust
two and three you're in first place and
there's no reason to think the cowboys
won't win that division they have yet to
play
any team in that division they've got
six games
coming up well other than the giants
they've beaten the giants they've got
five games left
against the eagles washington and the
giants so
the cowboys are they're they're they're
in it they're in it and
and you know maybe what happens here and
we've seen this with teams from time to
time chris
right the expectations will go away
they'll lower
you know sometimes teams wither under
the weight of heavy expectations and the
cowboys had
even with a new coach this year they had
big expectations in the season they have
big expectations
every season and maybe this in a
roundabout way
we'll just all right fine pressure's off
let's just go play the games one week at
a time yeah let's go
let's go take care of business and right
now of the four teams in the nfc east
i'd say they're the most likely to win
the division
and with one caveat if alex smith
can get back to the form that he was in
in 2018 then i'd worry about washington
but i think he's got a long way to go to
get back to 2018. yeah i would agree i
mean
the dallas team is still with that
offensive talent yeah
i just think i'd still put them in the
driver's seat i don't feel totally
confident about that
but i do feel that like man i would
expect the defense at some point to get
a little bit better here as we go
but i think you're right mike it kind of
like brings down expectations
it's gonna make them go back to the
drawing board a little bit we've talked
about this before sometimes when the
starter goes out
all of a sudden the coaches they start
to go wait some of those plays that
starter made
you know they weren't really because of
my plays they were because he was really
damn good and can make things happen off
schedule
now we gotta find some other creative
plays to help this guy
out right and that sometimes can jump
start a football team and
kind of bring them all together in the
locker room because nobody expects you
to win and it's us against the world so
we'll see where it goes offense is good
defense has got a lot of work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports